this is the remote control of the
universe every single thing that you are
sitting here on the ground or in a seat
hoping and dreaming could happen can
happen because of this the only thing
that's stopping you is your mental
perspective or your lack of knowledge on
how to do it no matter what you do
please get serious about LinkedIn
YouTube YouTube shorts Twitter X snap
Instagram Tik Tok please get serious the
attention of the entire world is on
these eight or nine platforms at scale
it cost costs zero money to post on it
this is an opportunity that has never
existed in the history of mankind and we
are all sitting here on our hands not
doing
enough